luxury stores are bursting with unsold
stuff okay weird unsold stuff luxury
fashion brands are grappling this Wall
Street Journal story grappling with an
excess of unsold stock due to slowing
sales after 15% rise in 2022 online
luxury sellers like my Teresa which
Vinnie which one you guys have heard of
my Teresa reported a 44% increase in
inventory luxury Brands protective of
their exclusivity have avoided deep
discounts and burning excess inventory
is now banned in the EU burning excess
inventory is banned in the EU they have
focused on opening concessions and
department stores to maintain control
over inventory and pricing off-price
Outlets are becoming popular choice for
luxury Brands representing 133% of
luxury good sales compared to 5% a
decade ago these Outlets provide a way
to clear stock while maintaining brand
perception with value retailers retail
uh Buy sister collection requiring
Brands to offer an average of 35%
discount to secure spot interesting Rob
can you go to the Rolex article I sent
you you know which one I'm talking about
with what's going on with Rolex with
watches watch this year if you can zoom
in the record Rush is that the same
article the record rush to buy Rolex or
pek Philip is over let me read that
article there in Bloomberg the biggest
ever boom in Swiss luxury watches is
coming to an end for 3 years the
industry enjoyed a surge of renewed
interest
that kicked off during the pandemic when
wealthy and cash flush consumers stuck
at home began drooling over luxury
mechanical wrist wear from Iconic Swiss
Brands the UNT turbocharged demand for
time pieces like AP Rolex and others
boosting Swiss watches export to record
sales damn $25 billion 25 billion Franks
which is 28 20 28 and a half billion
dollars Tom why do you think this is
taking place with these luxury products
especially with the watches
uh
well could it be that the so the Boom at
the top of the collector Market there
was no Boom at the top of the collector
Market um I I collect but uh not
voraciously watches great word great
word and the highend of the watch
collection Market hasn't gone away it's
still there and people that had the
money still have the money and they
collect them out of Interest
the middle of the market was
turbocharged by cheap money and the
cheap money has been spent and so now
the demand is down for the luxury items
as inflation and other things with the
economy have kind of it was a spike so
that that headline is actually correct
the rush to buy is over and people
rushed in and then they rushed out and
that's that's what's happening here um
when you take a look at um any of them
there's a a lot of them out there I'm
not going to plug one over the other but
you can get them and put an app on your
phone and you can basically see the
stock market for collectible watches the
same way you can see the stock market
for artwork or you know baseball cards
trading cards sports cards and the big
push with all that cheap money has come
and gone and so now the artificial
demand pushed the prices up now all of
those buyers have left the market and
the prices are coming back down you know
what the number along with the unit
they're down uh uh secondhand luxury
watch prices are near 2year low they're
down at this point roughly 40% little
shy 40% today 2ye low gee what happened
two years ago free money free money fake
money fake success that's right where I
was going to go with this so after in
2020 when the pandemic hit and all the
stimulus checks were coming out
everything was going on there I
predicted that the luxury Brands out
there the Gucci the Pras the Louis all
that were going to take a massive hit
but what ended up happening they got
richer so in the middle of the pandemic
most people don't know this guy's not a
household named Bernard alno he's the
owner of lvmh Louis Vuitton moed
Hennessy became the richest man in the
world at that time number two or three
okay jumped up he jumped up he passed
Bezos he passed musk now he's sitting
comfortably at number two elon's B worth
a quarter billion right now by the way
realtime billionair list on Forbes
Bernardo no is second place at 197
billion Jeff Bezos number three at 170
billion the list goes on but my
prediction was that all these luxury
Brands Who the hell's going to afford
all these Brands unbelievable who's
going to pay $5,000 for a purse turns
out your average stupid American who
gets a stimulus check for 3,600 bucks
isn't going to put that into their Roth
IRA they're going to put that on a purse
or a trip to Miami or go somewhere on
spring break we always say this that the
money's going to flow to the top people
aren just going to take this free money
and invest it in their 401K not going to
happen they're going to ball out they're
going to ball till they fall they're
going to try to keep up to the Joneses
they're going to basically try to fake
it till they make it and that's how you
have Bernard Alo the owner of lvmh BEC a
the second or first richest man in the
world because the average person that's
getting these stimulus checks is just
going to just spend all that money she's
going to make me move to Miami I mean
it's like it's they Beyond faked it
right they be what's that the the
consumer Beyond fake that not only they
spend their stimulus they took their
credit card debt from half a billion
from half a trillion
up to a trillion dollars Wells Fargo
said that the next report is probably
going to be knocking on 1.3 trillion and
bnpl is what they're using you know buy
now poor later you know see what's going
on well play Tom and so uh they they
they didn't just get drunk and go out
and buy things but now they're tapped
out and guess what's happening now the
brands are coming down but if you want
to see next year's fashion if you want
next year's fashion to be in your
favorite store here we go all we need to
do
is have all the looters come in and
steal this year's fashion the insurance
Mone on PNC will pay the retailer so
they can send it to Louis Vuitton and
refill the stores with next year's
fashion so there there are some
ecosystems in America that kind of you
know can can can help make it right I
only take fashion advice from the bisoc
that's it that's myy I'll be D you think
I'm going to watch GQ or something
stupid like that it's the bis duck
everyone knows that oh have you seen his
underwear ridiculous ridic
fitted thing you think Tom's a brief
boxers guy you haven't had Chilla
underwear you haven't really Tom but you
would be funny if Tom has like those
hammock silk oh banana hammock banana
hammock oh you
know the me my coffee woman yeah no no
by the way the audience right now is
having a great visualization of Tom and
a banana Hamm no no no if I talk like
that shout out to Lou I'm I'm not going
to e underwear I'm going to need a
cup you know give me my coffee woman
give my coffee woman so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here